a fan of your work is Andre capothy and
he's uh amongst many things also uh
writes occasionally a great blog he came
up with this idea I don't know if he
coined the term but of software 2.0
uh where the programming is done in the
space of configuring these artificial
neural networks
is there some sense in which that would
be the future of programming for us
humans where we're
less uh doing like python like
programming and more
how would you how would that look like
but basically doing the hyper parameters
of something akin to a biological system
and watching it Go and keeping it
adjusting it and creating some kind of
feedback loop within the system so
corrects itself yeah and then we watch
it over time
accomplish the goals we wanted to
accomplish is that kind of the the dream
of the the dogs the describing the
nature paper yeah yeah I mean that's
what you just painted is a very good um
description of our efforts at
regenerative medicine as a kind of
somatic Psychiatry so the idea is that
you're not you know you're not trying to
micromanage I mean think about the
limitations of of a lot of the medicines
today we try to interact down at the
level of Pathways right so so we're
trying to micromanage it what the what's
the problem well one problem is that for
almost every medicine other than
antibiotics once you stop it the problem
comes right back you haven't fixed
anything you were addressing symptoms
you weren't actually curing anything
again except for antibiotics uh that's
one problem the other problem is you
have massive amount of side effects
because you were trying to interact at
the lowest level it's right it's like
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to program this computer by changing
the the melting point of copper like
maybe you can do things that way but my
God it's hard to to program it right at
the hardware level so what what I think
we're we're starting to understand is
that and and by the way this goes back
to what you were saying before about uh
that we could have access to our
internal state right so people who
practice that kind of stuff right so
yoga and then biofeedback and those
those are all the people that uniformly
will say things like well the body has
an intelligence and the scenario like
those two sets overlap perfectly because
because that's exactly right because
once you once you start thinking about
it that way you realize that the better
locus of control is not always at the
lowest level this is why we don't all
program with a soldering iron right we
we take advantage of of the high level
intelligences that are there which means
trying to figure out okay which of your
tissues can learn what can they learn uh
what you know why is it that um certain
drugs stop working after you take them
for a while with this habituation right
and so can we understand habituation
sensitization associated of learning
these kinds of things in chemical
Pathways we're going to have a
completely different way I think we have
a completely different way of of using
drugs and of medicine in general when we
start focusing on the goal States and on
the intelligence of our subsystems as
opposed to treating everything as if the
only path was micromanagement from
chemistry upwards